reaction was to think of  her majesty the queen and  to feel a deep sense of sympathy  and compassion for her and for the whole  family  at the loss of such a gigantic figure  particularly in her own life married for  well over  70 years 73 years uh  i think i heard today there's only five  percent of the population  who were alive uh who have been  alive longer than uh the queen and  the duke of edinburgh had known each  other so  that was my first thought i think  secondly to feel  an extraordinary sense of um  what a remarkable life what a wonderful  life  of service of duty of  service to his country service  to the crown but with this  formidable intelligence  insight and a really extraordinary  prophetic gift